you say hook up it's the sex you're
bumping bellies you know that's just me
and my friends we get along pretty well
and we usually agree on everything but
there's one thing we just can't seem to
agree on and that is what it means to
hook up so I'm gonna go around the
office to ask my co-workers what it
means to hook up and hopefully we could
all finally come to an agreement from
like making out to like anal where would
you land the beginning of hooking up the
beginning of hooking up it's probably
just making out cuz that kid going to
you know hooking up once you get into
like anal like that you date but we need
you and your expertise for this video so
we're trying to figure out what it needs
to hook up and like I think hooking up
would definitely we if one private part
meets another private far more than just
making out otherwise you would just say
I made out with that person a [ __ ]
when you consider a [ __ ] hooking up a
person would be like I gave them a
[ __ ]
ah so if it's a hookup there's more
things what do you think it needs to
hook up I honestly think you need to
exchange some bodily fluids for it to
count as the hook-up I wouldn't really
go anything further than making out I
don't think I think I know people think
it's mean sex and I don't think that
they're wrong either
if someone says oh yeah we hooked up it
means you got an orgasm together
anything past kissing so close off I
think it means anything kissing or
beyond let's say you went out and you
kissed someone you looked at you that
I'm married and if my wife is somebody I
would say oh you hooked up with someone
and then we would be divorced as a
hookup I would say anything pass to just
making out anybody else has an opinion
about that I think it's having sex right
yes thank you confrontation if my friend
canteen was like I hooked up with
someone last night I'm like oh she had
sex with them or her would you be like
you didn't hook up with them if they
were like no we just I just like sucked
his dick yeah you'd be like that's not a
hookup my guess anything after like
making out Peter V V to V P to P I
probably wouldn't say that a make out as
a hookup what about a [ __ ]
that's a hookup I think I could come
here and tell you oh I hooked up with
this person last night and you would not
automatically assume I had sex with you
on my anyone automatically I think when
exposed genitalia Bernville that's when
the hookup line hit more than kissing so
it could be heavy touching heavy petting
fondling if you will horsing around
horsing around horsing around
yeah it's beyond making out you know
touching each other's bits you gotta be
naked for her go doesn't have to be sex
making out naked is that a hookup yeah
yeah there was some genitalia involved
there was something wasn't just a make
out anything beyond making out you can
kind of fill in with hookup and then you
just kind of get into more details
depending on who you're telling stories
then you have what they call hooking up
oh yeah
if you're hooking up yo like I've been
hooking up with this girl usually that
means you can sleep with the girl for me
I feel like hooking up involves like sex
in some way whether it's like oral or
like penetration like a [ __ ]
would you consider that hooking up
that's not your saying I don't think so
even though it is like sexual
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after this I think I'm more okay with
having a loose definition for hook up
even though I wish because I'll just
agree on something will remain confused
until we all get our [ __ ] together and
agree on something
I feel like I'm just as confused as I
was earlier
[Music]
[Music]